you just made a generalization we have
it from a spicy to know how to cook I
feel like my dream to cook
[Music]
[Music]
I eat it probably once or twice a year I
had rice last week this has always been
my favorite dish I don't know how to
make it but I know how to eat it I hope
today I like eat something and it like
just goes mean this is how I'm wondering
if Nigerian rice will be so different
that I will be able to automatically be
like nah this is not it I'm hungry
I'm plantains I do like fried bananas I
really am about to smell it though this
one smells a bit more like home it's
already taste amazing and so I'm just
gonna go ahead and say the distance
Nigerian I can taste the love of my
ancestors running through this new Ghana
Nigeria you sure yeah man this has got
that kick and this doesn't you feel
focused mmm are you Lee buying the
grains in half or something yeah this
one this is a weak sauces in a jar oh so
this is God began in every do not stand
firm in your decision I'll take this is
the Nigerian rice this will be the gun
young rice how does that make you feel
about about this beef that you everybody
makes sure left rice differently okay
I'm just gonna let you know that because
my mom and my aunt Sheila price is
thebomb.com
still feel like the way that like the
recipe is passed down and whatnot I'm
like everybody's taste buds on the way
to they flavor it it's different
but hey maybe it's just like everybody
shall off this different both Nigerian
jollof rice and guy named Dylan fight
it's good it's really good Ghana and
Nigeria